hey Forrest can we've never reviewed
being hit by a car
weird anyway what's it like to be
pranked Oh see that look at that you
were so afraid that's a great one it
looks like April Fool's has come a bit
early this year what do you think of
that nothing huh well here I go to get
pranked
should be a fun one right
at first being pranked appeared to be
just the assignment I needed after the
emotionally exhausting experience of
vetoing my ex-wife's request but then I
realized that since I can't prank myself
this had the potential to be uniquely
challenging hi Oh Brett well you could
talk to you about something this is very
difficult my two recent events but I'm
just going to cut to the chase and tell
you what I just learned
what is it review has been canceled why
did you just tell me the review has been
cancelled
great so no that can't be true no grant
branch no I know they can't do that
nobody can do that you can't dude you
don't do that you can't do that grant
hey listen to me what you are saying now
cannot happen No are you kidding me I
wish I were I guess
veto best thing from Suzanne trying to
get me either because you it's all me
dude no get back on the phone and you
tell them though if you do this the host
will kill himself we're doing more of
this absolutely not I'm in the middle of
a review right now but we're in the
middle of Jewish grants prank was a true
masterpiece of the form grant that was
me huh that was a little too good Oh
the most impressive thing about it was
that it took me a man who was waiting to
be pranked completely by surprise okay I
know that you're doing a segment on
being pranked right now but this is
actually real why would they cancel
review a really good idea well it's the
ratings oh they're really bad far as
have you noticed how a few questions
we've been getting your solution your
ex-wife asked a question that's how
these submissions we're getting I want
you to know that I did not tell just
lying down okay even though they're
buffing we have stairs to be a vice
president of the network I thought I
guess people just didn't care for the
show as much as we did you really
thought it through my god
thank you
okay this is a very nice fashion oh the
best pranks involved multiple people
bolstering one another's ridiculous
deceptions and this was a truly great
Frank oh boy we're really sorry about
what about the show getting canceled uh
yeah poor review getting canceled what
will become of the two of you well AJ
got a new show oh it's a travel show oh
yeah so she's gonna actually take us
with her and take us around the world
and she's going to pay us yes it's kind
of amazing yes that is I don't want to
go around the world and I want to get
paid I just want to work for mr. MacNeil
Josh endured what must have been
excruciating pain for the purpose of
this joke and for that I salute him are
you doing Oh as you would in the case of
a cancellation of the show yeah I love
you more than my Darrin okay best male
intern in a drama my staff and impressed
me in innumerable ways but their
dedication to helping me with my review
of being pranked was unprecedented there
we go and totally wonderful have you got
a farewell speech for me Lucille um
thank you this is actually the easiest
job I've ever had
that right yeah I've written free erotic
novels under the name Beverly la
Fontaine if he weren't checking out
thank you for letting me know that we'll
have to find more for you to do with the
future oh you're in denial okay you
should make this go smoother and I'm not
a very sentimental person but I'm glad
you got out of this gun show life oh yes
she's really leaving three days into
this prank I began to wonder just how
far this conspiracy of silliness
extended had my ex-wife and son been
roped into the fun as well but there was
no way of knowing because when I stopped
by their house
no one was home as the week came to a
close this prank revealed itself to be
fantastically elaborate this just goes
on and on oh now you can review what
it's like to be pranked love Josh and
Tina it's a bit of a head on a hat but
Josh and Tina were right
I could certainly review what it was
like to be pranked and it keeps getting
better because look who's not here AJ
Jason he's also playing along off to do
her Travel Show like it is a total
delight to see everyone in my world
working together to improvise a kind of
a comic play though I did feel a bit
foolish at first I mostly feel very
fortunate to be surrounded by people who
care enough about me and my work to go
to such great plants
now if I have one criticism is that this
prank was not really all that believable
because what kind of a universe would be
cruel enough to allow review to be
canceled right after I chose it over my
family come on but all in all I give
being pranked five really fun stars
that's all the time we have for review
see you next time
you